e aí
eu convido vocês a conhecerem um pouco
do meu mundo nada extraordinário mas a
vida que escolhi ter antes de falar de
mim gostaria de saber aqui quem um ano
passado rompeu alguma amizade sabe
aquele amigo que você não fala mais com
aquele parente que você tem que evitar
e quem é que nas festas de final de ano
entre os familiares ou os amigos falam
sobre política
e o sobre religião ou sobre gênero
e qual foi a última vez que você olhou
no olho de outra pessoa e falou sobre
seus medos seus sonhos ou simplesmente
sobre a vida
e qual foi a última vez que alguém te
revelou algo de dentro
e as conversas estão difíceis
nós falamos muito de forma colaborativa
de trabalho valorização das relações
humanas porque percebo que as pessoas
estão mais facilmente cortando os seus
relacionamentos se afastando e se
isolando
nós falamos de boca cheia tenho tantos
amigos no face estou conectado no mundo
o mais engraçado é que temos uma
tendência nos aproximar só das pessoas
que achamos parecidas com a gente
e quem é que conhece um caçador
esportivo que amigo de uma pessoa
protetora dos animais
é porque o diferente me faz afastar dos
outros
e vejam se essa cena é conhecida você
manda uma mensagem para um amigo teu ele
não te respondi no momento nem no mesmo
dia que que você pensa como você reage
e já faz uma hora que eu mandei a
mensagem já deve ter dado tempo ele sair
do banho
hum será que eu fiz alguma coisa errada
que ele tá brava comigo
eu não sei porque eu insisto nessa
amizade está óbvio que para ele na mesma
coisa
da próxima vez eu vou demorar uma semana
para responder a mensagem dele e os mais
drásticos já que ele não quer me
responder vou bloquear seu contato no
meu caso eu encontrei com essa pessoa
depois de uma semana fui toda sorrisos
abraçá-la falando que tava com saudade
dela fala com aquele tom de mágoa eu te
mandei uma mensagem e você não me
respondeu eu pergunto quando sexta
passada sexta passada eu troquei o meu
celular e naquele dia perdi um monte de
mensagem e aconteceu isso comigo mesmo
eu não sei se alguns se identificarão
com que eu falei outros pensaram coisas
diferentes mas nós temos alguma coisa em
comum
o whats smu de fato nós sabemos o que
aconteceu quantas vezes a gente tira o
nosso achismo do bolso e faz conclusões
precipitadas que nos faz afastar e até
romper relacionamento
e vamos pensar um pouquinho que está por
trás dessas conversas como eu converso
com outro por causa do whatsapp
e a pessoa que não respondeu a minha
mensagem porque é um descaso com a minha
pessoa
é porque eu sou responsável pelo outro
responder ou não a mensagem
é porque eu precisava falar com aquela
pessoa era urgente ou eu tava sozinho eu
não tinha nada para fazer e fica
brincando no celular
e se eu não tenho claro o que eu penso e
sinto como eu posso dizer saber o que o
outro penses em quando as pessoas falam
normalmente a gente pega a sala daquela
pessoa e tem que encaixar dentro de uma
caixinha que fomos construindo ao longo
de nossas vidas e que muitas vezes não
percebemos dependendo da fala do outro a
gente pode por dentro da caixinha do
rótulo aquele cara é um ignorante eu não
vou conversar com ele ou no julgamento
aquilo tá certo aqui tá totalmente
errado
o ou do fingimento sabe aquela história
que a pessoa tá falando você tá assim
vai ser tá pensando em outra coisa que
eu não tenho nada a ver
e o ainda do da defesa a pessoa fala na
primeira palavra que a pessoa falou eu
bloqueio a minha escuta e começou a
elaborar uma resposta para aquela
primeira palavra existem várias
caixinhas como construímos essas
caixinhas somos seres relacionais eu
construo o meu eu de acordo com o
feedback que eu tenho do mundo exterior
desde a gestação
hoje trazemos uma genética única e uma
experiência vivida dentro do útero um
exemplo a mãe durante a gravidez ingere
bebida alcoólica ou falta a ferro o bebê
pode desenvolver doenças neurológicas
quando nascemos continuamos com essa
interação com o meio ambiente e com as
pessoas o bebê ao chorar ele ele recebe
uma mensagem do mundo externo alguém
pode pegar no colo ou dá um alimento e
ele dispensa nele e uma nova reação ele
pode dormir ou se acalmar e para cada
pessoa é diferente e nós podemos ser
diferentes em cada na mesma situação de
formas variadas um exemplo do bebê a mãe
quando escuta o bebê chorar pode pensar
acho que ele tá sujo vou trocar a fralda
o pai pode pensar acho que ele tá com
fome vou dar uma madeira a mãe a vó pode
pensar
e tadinha deve está se sentindo sozinho
vou pegar no colo só um pouquinho o bebê
estimula cada um de formas diferentes e
cada um reage de acordo com que traz na
sua própria construção do durante toda a
sua vida e vai estimular o bebê a reagir
de formas diferentes qual é a chance que
vocês acham de quando o bebê quiser um
colo e ver a vó passar ele vai chorar
e quer ver outro exemplo a gente reage
da mesma maneira sempre um amigo teu te
chama de bobo é capacitor de risada tem
alguém que não é tão amigos eu te chama
de bobo é capaz que você se oferta
ah pois bem
e se podemos ser diferentes a cada
instante se podemos ter uma construção
única e diversa porque o outro não pode
ter totalmente diferente de mim porque o
que é óbvio para mim tem que ser óbvio
para o outro qual é a resistência que eu
tenho do diferente não sou eu ou você
mais a grande maioria se dois são iguais
um se torna redundante
é a diferença pode ser um estímulo para
o crescimento e mudança uma oportunidade
de ampliar minhas ideias e perspectivas
mas para eu não cair as no meu achismo
eu tenho que conferir conferir ideias
conferir pensamentos entendimentos e até
as palavras eu sei o que eu quero dizer
mas eu não sei o que você entendeu do
que eu disse
e o vídeo uma pessoa que as palavras são
como empadas cabe em qualquer recheio um
exemplo palavra educação para alguns
pode significar uma pessoa agradável e
gentil para outros um nível de
escolaridade existe o certo o errado o
que percebo é que quando as pessoas
conseguem estabelecer um significado de
incomum a conversa consegue evoluir e
quando a gente começa a ter esses
pequenos cuidados a gente começa a ver
qual é a nossa pa qual é a nossa
responsabilidade e aí começamos a ser
protagonistas das nossas próprias vidas
bom e quando a gente para de querer que
o outro seja como a gente quer ou que a
gente imagina o outro para de se
defender daí a conversa flui fica mais
fácil e a gente consegue fazer
verdadeiras conexões um teatro em
harvard fez um estudo sobre o
desenvolvimento adulto e dentre as
coisas que ele descobriu ele viu que as
pessoas mais satisfeitas com seus
relacionamentos mais conectadas com o
outro seu corpo e seu cérebro permanecem
saudáveis por muito mais tempo
e eu confesso que eu havia perdido esta
consciência
oi para mim eu era dona da verdade
e aí descobri a mediação transformativa
reflexiva o nome é pomposo mas é uma
coisa muito simples como conversar pude
refletir o que ouço o que penso e como
reage a
eu percebi que tem uma oportunidade de
mudar quando eu converso melhor estou
com outro que é diferente de mim eu
posso construir coisas novas ampla e
diversa e quando as pessoas fecham a
porta para esta conversa mediação ajuda
abrir a
e o mediador é um profissional formado
que ajuda nesta conversa que está
trancada por ele não fazer parte dessas
questões ele não julga no aponta
caminhos e não interfere nos resultados
simplesmente organize o espaço dessa
conversa para um poder ouvir o outro e
ouvir assim mesmo
e a mediação serve para qualquer
situação onde envolva duas ou mais
pessoas pais e filhos amigos irmãos
sócios professor-aluno empregado
empregador a ideia é transformar o
conflito de algo destrutivo para algo
construtivo fazendo pelas pessoas
resgate tem esta forma de conversar
resgatando o poder de decisão sobre suas
próprias vidas e independentemente do
resultado um exemplo um casal vem para
mediação e alterno resolvem se separar
tudo bem se for precisão deles porque
com certeza essa separação não vai ser
com guerra com briga e sim com um
diálogo onde eles possam construir
acordos que sejam bom para os dois todos
saem ganhando que a mediação é pontual
porque são poucos encontros
eu vou fazer um convite para vocês
eu vou pedir em 10 segundos que causa um
tem esse consigo próprio desta minha
fala o que fez sentido ou não fez
sentido de algo que tocou vocês e peço
para que guardem isso que nós vamos lá
um pouquinho mais para frente pode ser
vamos lá
bom obrigada agora eu vou pedir para que
vocês olhem para pessoa que está sentada
ao seu lado se for alguém que você
conhece tenta imaginar que a primeira
vez que você tá vendo essa pessoa vocês
vão falar o seu nome e vão falar do que
desses 10 segundos que vocês pensaram o
que para vocês fez sentido ou não desta
minha fala mas eu vou pedir um favor
enquanto um estiver falando o outro não
m nenhum comentário simplesmente escutem
e depois a gente vai trocar quem ouviu
fala quem falou pode ser vamos lá o nome
e compartilhem o que vocês pensaram
e aí
o ok obrigada agora quem falou ouvir e
quem ouviu fala pode ser vamos lá
oi ok
bom obrigada
e como foi sentir alguma coisa diferente
como foi simplesmente ouvir o outro às
vezes esquecemos de ouvir quem está mais
próximo da gente e sabemos o que ele já
está pensando lembra daquela amizade
rompida ou daquele parente que tentamos
evitar vamos dar uma chance para você e
para o outro na próxima interação tentem
perceber o outro exatamente como ele é
tentem ter um genuíno interesse em saber
como ele pensa e sente pertence perceber
o que é fala do outro está me tocando e
aproveita a oportunidade de rever suas
ideias ampliá-las ou simplesmente
confirmá-la e lembrem está tudo bem se
você não vão concordar com outro para
manter a conexão não dependemos disso só
depende
a querer e quando eu consigo conversar
melhor eu consigo fazer uma conexão com
o outro e comigo mesmo agradeço a
oportunidade de poder de compartilhar o
meu eu de hoje com vocês
[Aplausos]